let's bring an energy bill it's the ESPN
college basketball analyst Sports Emmy
nominated outstanding sports personality
in the sports event analyst category
gets Bill Raftery Chris Collinsworth
Kirk Herbstreit John Smoltz and the
eventual winner Tony Romo please say
hello to
[Music]
who else is in the category you go Oh
Bob Costas is in there and you go okay I
don't have to worry about a speech Jay
good to see you too are you gonna have a
speech ready for the sports Emmys I am
Jay I go when when I've been fortunate
to be nominated you just go and clap for
the winner yes you know you got no shot
first of all I got no shot in football
because you're going against football
but you know Tony Romo is gonna way you
have no shot why don't you do your
speech right now I know I couldn't even
think of why I wouldn't even and the
winner for outstanding sports
personality in the sports event analyst
category is Tony Romo Jay Bilas then I
go then you go like this no but then you
go like this and you pretend that you're
ok with it well I've gotten used I've
gotten very good at that with Bob Costas
like there are seat fillers I'm like an
applause filler because I I start and
the winner and I start applauding right
away I will tell you this and and this
is no no BS on this I didn't know they
existed until the first time I was
nominated and so when you went to the
it's a wonderful event and then you're
kind of looking around going god I can't
believe I'm a member of this industry
it's pretty good it's really cool yes
you're going to look at all these
amazing pros and that's not even that
doesn't even cover the the true
landscape of all the pro mazing pros out
there but then when the category comes
up and you lose its deflating and my god
like that sucked okay I show up with the
dance we got nominated last year I got
nominated for studio host so we lost
early as a team I have to wait until the
next to last award and then I lose again
to Bob Costas I left in between the
first loss in the second loss
I went got a beer I just went downstairs
to a restaurant i sat there by myself
because I'm like you know I I want to
win but I wanted us to win and then when
we ditched that one of the worst losses
I've ever had like I was I was really
defeated well I mean I I actually felt
the same way and then but but then you
go you know go out take your wife out to
dinner go with friends and then somebody
says you know but it's so
it's so nice to be nominated now I'd
rather be playing golf right now like
this is really nice I mean I'm dying
you're making light up but but when it
when when that kind of thing does happen
and you lose you know you have to you
have to clap politely but you're really
going yeah you know as Tony Romo changed
how you've called games now has he
changed any is he changing the industry
do you think no because if you if you
are going to try to call things out in
advance one that's not what I'm
interested in doing like I know what
certain teams are running what kind of
out of bounds plays and all that stuff
my challenge honestly just with my
personality has been try not to make the
game into some clinic EXO no clinic you
know because you want to say hey look at
the screen for the screener actions and
people people like what I years ago and
this kind of opened my eyes this years
ago I was working with Chris Fowler
doing doing raps like half times of
stuff
and we had a highlight up and I said I
said your boy is a great action awful
flex cut here and then we went to break
and he goes what is a flex guy and so I
diagram the Flex offense for him then I
realized like look he's been doing this
a million years and heard flex cut a
million times and didn't know what it
was and when I watch a football game I'm
a casual football fan I love football
but like when they're talking about trap
blocking and all these different things
yeah yeah a gap and all that stuff I
mean that's going way over my head I'm
not saying I don't want to hear it but
but at times you're kind of going I'd
really like to just watch the game and
so I try to do that in basketball where
you try to back off a little bit and I'm
not sure how good I am it backing off
that's and it's tough because sometimes
you guys are so close to it and you
forget how close you are where they're
giving you terminology like this I think
Collinsworth is very good at taking
something complicated and making it
sound a little simpler there and he does
it in that southern draw of his as well
so it just doesn't feel like it's you
know your you're looking at a chalkboard
here you're at a Harvard seminar raff is
the same way rafter he just celebrates
the game and you could stand he knows
the game obviously but that's the key I
always think the people who translate
and make it so it's bite-sized
consumable that's where you can your
you're a star yeah people are watching
the game to enjoy the game they're not
going to a basketball clinic or a
football clinic so you can balance it
out I mean I remember when I was a kid I
loved baseball and I was watching Vin
Scully and joe gergiolla we're doing a
game and Gary's Yola says pitch out and
they pitched out got the runner going a
second if Vin Scully goes how did you
know that and he said well he used this
I used a fist that's the sign for that
and I was like oh my god you know but he
wasn't doing it all the time he wasn't
calling out every pitch and saying okay
here comes a curve ball because he knew
what the signs were he did it he did a
couple times explained it and Scully
asked him about it but it was there it
was within the rhythm of the game
I think Tim McCarver was doing that in
baseball and then it started to annoy
people that Tim would say I tell ya and
then he would tell you something and I
love the nuance the subtle nuance of
baseball where you just go man I'd I
didn't see that
you know Ripken's left foot is open a
little bit because he's got to cheat a
little bit like those things are just
fun to hear and I thought McCarver was
one of the first who gave you a little
bit of a head start and you can do some
of that stuff we're on a replay in
basketball like if a guy's coming off a
screen you could say hey the defender
needs to make him you know when Reggie
Miller used to used to be able to come
off either side honestly you have to
give them a direction you know you can
point little things out like that on a
replay but if you're doing that all game
long that's pretty old
he's Jay Bilas Sports Emmy nominated
what's your answer on the poll question
if you said to the Knicks they can have
Zion or you're gonna have Kevin Durant
oh I dig Durant yeah cuz I'm not sure
what I have was I on yeah that's exactly
I know what I have with Durant
you've got a guy who's gonna lead the
league in scoring yeah but what do I
have it what do you think that that's
the best player in the league right now
you think yes I do
he's about right now he's the best
player in the league now that now LeBron
has not been healthy this year and and
has been with the lesser team like
LeBron LeBron has been the best player
but right now he's the best player
Durant's most players see I still think
Yanis is that he's taken a team that
doesn't appear to be formidable and
there
60 games he might even great I think
yeah but but I think if you put Duran on
that team they'd win 60 games too if you
if you swapped it out that really that
dudes the real thing okay you can score
from anywhere anytime like nobody in
guard that guy yes but you also have the
honest who could be the Defensive Player
of the Year yeah no I mean I'm not
you're talking about it's kind of like
the LeBron Michael hey you know yeah you
can sit and get your undies in a bunch
over it but you're talking about the two
best ever and you've got the two best in
the game now or two of the best in the
game and I just I would take I would
take Durant first yeah I I just don't
know what we have in Zion here I think
there's a fascination I don't know if
he'll ever be hotter his brand if you go
beyond her you think he's he's gonna be
if he stays healthy he will be but you
can a billion dollar player you can end
up as in a bad franchise sure and then
you're sort of stuck there feels and
it'll be a highlight reel and every game
he plays he's different he's different
like when the season started and and we
were like I you know if my soundbite of
when somebody asked me you know describe
him and I said oh my god in that you
know yeah and yeah just tell people look
that you don't have to take my word for
it when you see it you won't believe it
and you'll know and everybody did like
look what he did for basketball this
year and look our ratings were way up
they were up for I'm sure more than one
reason but the biggest reason was him
and so when people say man I'm so tired
of these one and done you know you can't
you can't follow the game like he used
to first of all they're all wrong like
the one and Dunn's have been nothing but
great for college basketball absolutely
great ratings if you look at the ratings
and the amount of people that watched
before the one-and-done rule came in it
was less than it is during the
one-and-done so people will say well I
don't watch now cuz the one who does
they're lying and the ones who are our
age to say well the game was so much
easier to follow I knew all the players
want to know you didn't when we were
younger there was the game of the week
yeah and that was it so you knew DePaul
Notre Dame UCLA you know you might have
known Kentucky and some of these other
teams but the people who act like they
knew everybody they're lying
most people didn't know Larry
bird until he played in the n-c-double-a
tournament his his last year in 1979 who
would you compare as far as having an
impact like Zion in the history of
college basketball in the history of
college basketball there's been no well
there's never been anyone like him on a
basketball court in any level he's he's
truly unique in that regard but as far
as impact is concerned I mean I don't
even think the Fab Five had had the kind
of impact that these guys have had this
year like Zion was the he was the the
North Star of the game fan 5 was big
though what's that fab 5 they were big
but they didn't have the same kind of
coverage as these guys have now
everything was more local back then it's
not close because I've had like Brian
Dutcher was was an assistant head coach
San Diego State now who just succeeded
Steve Fisher he was an assistant that
recruited all those guys and and they
were in Maui this year and I asked him
you know they had to play Duke and I
asked him how does this compare to the
hype of the Fab five because it is not
close there is way more on these guys
well social media - and the fact that
ESPN is a TV show yeah Duke basketball
is a TV show oh it's a it's it's bigger
than the Kardashian show I mean if we
could put their practices on we would
yeah and people would watch them and so
everything it's almost like every
network whether it's it's us CBS you
name it they couldn't get enough Zion
and if you didn't have Zion in your show
you were making a mistake and I know
some people recoiled at it saying I get
it he's good can we talk about something
else but but you're like wait a minute
now like what do we it's like going to a
golf tournament and saying you're not
gonna talk about Tiger Woods yeah you
know cuz Zach Johnson's hitting the ball
really well ball striking has been great
you know you're not gonna do that you're
its tiger even if Tigers playing poorly
which which hasn't happened lately but
even if he's playing poorly he's more
compelling than the rest of the game
that's just the way it is it's not right
wrong or indifferent that's the way it
is and that's the way it's been was ion
this year what would he be worth open
market one year in college yeah I don't
know it's just whatever I think it's
whatever anybody would want to pay like
you know right now I mean I've heard a
little bit before you talk about well
the NC double-a maybe open the name
image and likeness no they're not
they're just saying that they're not
open to anything because the next thing
they
is well but nobody's come up with a
workable plan and you're like okay I got
a workable plan it's called the free
market it's right next to the plan that
pays everybody else you know what
where's the panted the plan that pays
all the coaches there's no plan for that
yeah you know they're not saying well
wait a minute what about what about we
can't have inequities in the system like
Duke can't pay more for Coach K then
Austin Peay is paying for its coach
that's not fair and and we don't want to
have like the the assistants aren't
making the same as the head coach what
about the landscape professionals how do
we pay them how do we value them oh my
god it's so complicated they're they're
full of it they are not looking at this
in one way shape or form the the rice
Commission brought it up they're getting
hit left and right with it but then
they'll say well the Olympics only has
one country we've got 350 Division one
institutions plus 1100 how we gonna do
it it's impossible like come on man you
know you put a tournament on make a
billion dollars a year and that's just
the tournament yeah that has nothing to
do with conference money and all this
stuff it's funny how they can figure out
who they know exactly who to pay in the
tournament and they know all these
schools know exactly whom to recruit and
exactly who to put in the game when they
need to win but they don't know that
what everybody's worth who wins who wins
Saturday I think it's Michigan State but
I didn't I didn't think Michigan State
was gonna get past Duke but I think
it'll be Michigan State Virginia those
are the those are the two best teams but
man Texas Tech's playing really well
there they're like Indiana used to be in
the old days they'd run motion offense
so they'd run a lot of you know down
screen back screen fade screen stuff you
can't really you can't really scout it
you got tendencies that you go with but
they're they're good and you went some
college basketball jargon yeah yeah
exactly
yeah do you think Chris beard is staying
at Texas Tech I don't know you remember
he was at UNLV for like to eat he talked
about that yesterday yeah so you know
now that now while the instability is
like trying to get rid of grad transfers
because you know they've got coaches
doing that's and I'm not saying it's not
the right move but you know he had Nate
oats at Buffalo signed an extension to
stay at Buffalo and left in Alabama like
six days later nine days later and they
want to talk about the players well
don't understand commitment and
accountability and like what like look
fine I get it like the coaches can do
what they want I don't have any problem
with them moving around yeah but don't
tell me about commitment and
responsibility your institution when
they sign a contract and leave a few
days later like that that's out the door
in the discussion well could you see
beard going to use he didn't handle my
question very well yesterday when I
asked him he just went uh I'm here to
win a game he I could I I mean I could
see that happening is UCLA a great place
no not anymore it's a great place it's
not the job that they believe it okay
and it because if it were they'd get the
coaches they want you know like look
look who they have been hiring and like
they're they're falling backwards on
Jamie Dixon now according to reports
that the buyouts an issue so they offer
48 mil to Calipari but then the buyouts
the problem with Jamie
how does Calipari get a deal if he
doesn't want to like I don't know how
this works that he he's gonna join us
but he he's got a lifetime deal whatever
that means at Kentucky so how does he
get to the point with UCLA where they
actually offer him a contract here what
do you mean how does he get the point
well done he did he just little done
that channel you want to just flirt to
get a new deal at Kentucky probably I
mean you know every once in a while and
I'm not speaking just to Calipari here
but every once in a while it's good to
shake up your admit this every year when
yeah because you know you know how
leverage works I mean you when you have
it you need to use it and so I don't
blame it like what UCLA is doing and
they've done this every time they make
somebody a lot of money and then they
wind up settling for whatever they have
settle for yeah and that's that's
nothing against the coaches they've
hired they're all good good coaches and
good guys but they think they think that
they should get the but that Coach K
should leave Duke and and hightail it
out to LA and that's just not and
they're gonna do the same thing with
Tony Bennett and they'll probably make
him a bunch of money and and that'll be
the that'll be the end of it if you want
to hang with fellow losers you can hang
with us at the Sports Emmy like we have
the losers loan you know what I don't
think I can go this year because my kids
are graduating isn't it like May 20th
yeah my kids are graduating from college
that day I have to I have one graduating
from under
a week for us the other graduating for
Business School okay and so I think my
vow to make it my guys will accept on
your behalf
they don't have to accept on my behalf
they have to clap on my behalf
well there's no winning it's not gonna
happen but if you do pull it's not false
humility this is not gonna happen
you have no hero and you never do though
because your college basketball's going
up against don't you guys hope bilis
wins now you don't have to worry about
better chance ion comes back to Duke are
you winning the sports
[Laughter]
that's your poll clip yes it'll be 99 to
1 and my mother will be the only one
great to see you Jay thank you for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]